hey how's it going I'm here today with
special guests actually not so special
guests I mean of course no where are you
going what's going on fix hey what's
going on PJ - peril a different language
oh yes I am a big speaker of many
languages is that what dumbass broken
game we're playing today what do you
mean dumbass broken game okay this is a
great game so thanks little bit language
maybe yes okay
as you can tell we are in a different
part of the world today
wha how's that the Eiffel Tower behind
us
yes I do believe wow it's so pointy I've
always wanted to go to France yeah I
mean not so much let's play the language
game let's do it so high this game there
is you have to guess the language the
great language game a great language
game that's right and there's a reward
for winning is it a feature spinner god
damn it wow you're you will get to spin
the fidgets spinner ever I go on well
this one is okay well there's a
punishment what you lose the play is the
punishment I don't get the figures yes
and you will get hurt by the spinner
okay yeah and depending how many wrong
that's how many spins you can charge it
up Wow got it okay yes okay got it
yeah sounds good let's do it let's do it
alright you are the guest I'll let you
start
alright thanks really
actually no straight pyrimidines ethics
to live Nanook yellow station robotic
reliever at the sway order posny oh okay
yeah I hear what you're saying yeah
mmhmm yeah I'm gonna take a wild guess
come on I'm gonna guess that it is
Russia damn it yeah hey 50 points not
bad I heard dad died ruble to you which
is working Oh in Russian yeah this is
one of the few words I know you know
better Russian and know a bit of Russian
I'm a man of many languages just like
you said a man of the world
Amanda that's what you say the intro to
the very polar ymt and I think
particularly in the yes
[Music]
Susa Dido ah ciancia knows Spanish I've
been to Spain
I've got Spanish friends here the guys
that a deviation because you're
offending everyone my favorite fans in
the Telugu I don't know is it Haitian
Haitian I think that's how you pronounce
it from Haiti okay sorry I'm not I'm not
entirely sure of myself but this is your
guy like I said and then deviation beep
okay okay Turkish it was Asian
it was Haitian I like you knew that I
like you knew that I may have added
inkling
knee-jerk um a root hid no no the engine
the Gihon American winger Boko Haram
yeah Monica she'll need your camera but
is the house that I know what it's not
hey I'm speaking Howser
what's a Felix seriously there are
people watching this who speak houses
[ __ ] you houses fluently oh my god no
way I can win Boko Haram yeah so much
human I know you know it's not Haitian
yes in theory I know it's not German I
don't think it's Korean
yeah [ __ ] house then I don't think
it's Chinese I'm gonna go with Howser
[ __ ] how's that thank you
people people who know people who speak
out all over the world this place is the
worst
this is I love this place is my favorite
worse place I've ever been it I'm loving
it here yes and BuzzFeed so score so far
like three one no three two three two
okay we trying cheap now not just
listening Bonnie
Ling bunny caw caw caw all uppity some
cause we write our new things learn you
be home home it was Chinese woo what the
[ __ ] is the world
Caprica you Chi Alpha Delta partay arrow
portal de la sharm el-sheikh are a
difficult urge KU numeral Mari deeper
funny carry words a pledget in Egypt
that's a difficult one because I don't
think it's Italian because there's not
enough kind of like it's definitely not
Italian that's what I'm saying it's not
enough it's not going off like Italian
kind of like there's very sense sounds
in Italian language it's not that
difficult numeral Mari deeper funny
carry words a pledget in Egypt yeah
we'll go with between Romanian I know it
could be Romanian could be us back 5050
PJ were scared
[ __ ] you Michael you naughty we faked
Romanian in on a frog the native would
stencil what the [ __ ] is in Africa hands
well that's the language they spawn like
free when I said you're a man of the
world
I was my miss judge chief what what
you're a man of Sweden it just seems
kind of weird it's like you come from
Europe and you're like I speak you're a
pants okay whatever Africans Africans
again I guess hell yeah top align save
storing emotionally with stage I think I
know miss to my boot but an opportunity
to turn of China love secretive yeah I
might think possibly yes god damn it
we're always fine oh yeah Thank You Ida
let's go push together yeah mondo TPP
kami got Mangano phony don't enjoy
hurting ho tree hugger to kick in ting -
yeah my point you [ __ ] you don't get
this one I will punch you what I will
punch you know that we know punching a
wall punch you fidget spinner or
otherwise okay I will punching I think
it was trying I will tell Aaron nanny
kissing it no more
the to poppers day okay where are we in
the world where are we okay well I
always feel it shut up got lost
I'm I we took the wrong bus and now
we're here how do we get here some ring
a bus that's a clue good
Kobe level so cord wrapped clip it roll
I will go in her toes
which one is it
well I knew today
[Music]
[Applause]
alright you get three you get three
fidgets spins
3y3 that's how many go wrong alright um
can you pass me the green one no not the
green one
Oh green screen away right actually that
might be cool
cue bangs oh wow let's go some weight to
it yeah go down yeah
nice okay yeah try this one
sure oh yeah this is like a very this is
very like I think of all my all my years
of freedom spinning this is definitely
not a good weight to it
yeah all your years all my year many
years of experience that were talking to
him around 24 minutes damn dude 24
minutes almost as long as this recording
yeah that's incredible
okay okay you ready yes where do you
want to be fidget spun on the butt yeah
I'm not doing that I'm not I didn't say
the but you're presenting your butt to
me it's very obvious what you're
implying you got a problem with a I know
everything about your soundboard UX why
do you wanna be finished on that's not
okay good sheep the cheek yes seriously
okay but don't make me blind
he died he died everybody PewDiePie
pewdie died